Matt taibi who is who is a lefty
journalist or at least has been a lefty
journalist his whole life he is one of
the guys that Elon Musk has been leaking
these Twitter files to he had a long
thread yesterday about russiagate and of
course Russia gate which ultimately led
to Donald Trump being impeached in a
whole bunch of other things it basically
sounds like the entire thing was a
complete fabrication so he had a crazy
long thread we picked just some of the
highlights so bear with me as I read
some of these for you here and uh and
then we'll go from there so thread
Twitter files 14 the russiagate lies the
fake tale of Russian Bots and the
hashtag release the memo hashtag at a
crucial moment in a years-long fury
Democrats denounced a report about flaws
in the trump-russia investigation saying
it was boosted by Russian Bots and
trolls Twitter officials were aghast
finding no evidence of Russian influence
we are feeding Congressional trolls not
any significant activity connected to
Russia putting the cart before the horse
assuming this is propaganda slash Bots
these are obviously quotes from Twitter
employees uh four Twitter warned
politicians and media the that not only
they lacked evidence but had evidence
the accounts weren't Russian and were
roundly ignored
on January 23 2018 Senator Dianne
Feinstein and congressman Adam Schiff
published an open letter saying the
hashtag gained the immediate attention
and assistance of social media accounts
linked to Russian influence operations
Connecticut Senator Richard Blumenthal
followed suit publishing a letter saying
we find it reprehensible that Russian
agents have so eagerly manipulated
innocent Americans couple more for you
Feinstein Schiff Blumenthal and media
members all pointed to the same Source
the Hamilton 68 dashboard created by
former FBI counterintelligence official
Clint Watts under the auspices of the
alliance for securing democracy the
dashboard which featured a crude picture
of Vladimir Putin deviously blowing evil
red Twitter Birds into the atmosphere
was vague in how it reached its
conclusions I encourage you to be
skeptical of Hamilton's 68's take on
this which as far as I can tell is the
only source for these stories said
Global policy Communications Chief and
future White House and NSC NSC spokesman
Emily horn she added it's a comms play
for ASD couple more here Roth couldn't
find any connection to the release the
memo at all I just reviewed the accounts
that posted the first 50 tweets with
hashtag release the memo and none of
them show any signs of affiliation to
Russia when Twitter spoke to a
Blumenthal staffer they tried to wave
him off because we don't don't believe
these are Bots Twitter Executives even
tried to negotiate implying an
undisclosed future PR concession if
Blumenthal would lay off on this it
seems like there are other wins we could
offer him Blumenthal published his
letter anyway in essence the Russian bot
Story the Russian collusion story it was
all made up and not only was it all made
up
the people that were pushing it Dianne
Feinstein Adam Schiff Blumenthal
basically the entire Democrat machine
which ultimately led to two impeachments
certainly the first one
um it was all complete nonsense and they
knew it if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell